order order in the court today we are
sentencing the most larious group of
criminals to ever sail the grand line we
the court of Enis Lobby on behalf of the
prosecution the world government hereby
pronounce the straw hat Pirates Monkey D
Luffy Roan NOA Zoro Vince smok Sandry
cat burglar Nami Tony Tony Chopper Nico
Robin Cy flam AKA cyborg Frankie Soul
King Brook and former Lord jimbe guilty
of everything theft kidnapping murder
death is too lenient a punishment for
them so these criminals will be locked
up in infil down and monkey duffi don't
even think about another Prison Break
we've upgraded security and the warden
will be keeping a close eye on you in
the newly constructed level seven which
straw hat I assure you is a very very
bad place with no meat at all the time
you will all spent their total
7,821 years here is the list of all
crimes committed by the straw hat
Pirates wow I mean what exactly did the
straw heads do to get a sentence like
this but we've done extensive research
like a stupidly huge amount of research
that will forever tarnish all of our
Google search results to find out what
amount of jail time real life criminals
would have gotten for equivalent crimes
where they are applicable at least so
here's the complete list of all crimes
committed by the straw head Pirates and
how many years of prison they get for
each of them starting with Captain
Monkey D Luffy son of dragon the
Revolutionary who already at the young
age of seven committed the crime of
grand Larsen when he stole and consumed
an exceedingly rare and extremely
valuable devil fruit from the emperor of
the sea red-haired Shanks 6 years in
prison Grand larsy by the way which I've
heard in like a million TV shows
apparently means theft or something
worth a total of $50,000 or more and a
devil fruit like Luffy's definitely does
seem rare and expensive enough to
qualify here next roronoa Zoro once a
quite promising Bounty Hunter working
against the pirate scum it does seem
like he changed his ways when he
murdered a dog belonging to the
lieutenant Commodore helppo of the
Marines and in the court of public
opinion and that of John Wick murdering
a dog is an even more heinous action
than killing a human so 10 years in
prison and then during soro's subsequent
imprisonment Luffy illegally freed him a
crime also worthy of 5 years in prison
he then resisted arrest and this will be
a common theme in this video as you'll
see they resist arrest just about
everywhere that they go and so an
additional year for each of them now
both of these Pirates assaulted multiple
officers of the law at two years per
Marine punched an additional 20 years
just here and on top of it all Luffy
destroyed public property in the form of
a giant statue of Captain axan Morgan 10
years on top of it so yeah uh settle in
everyone because that's 53 years already
and we've barely even gotten started let
me tell you because now cat burglar Nami
don't think we've forgotten about her
for petty theft of a grand line map from
buy the clown one year and that's of
course in addition to stealing a boat
from his crew mates and what amounts to
Grand Theft Auto I mean Grand Theft
Naval two and a half years did you know
that Grand Theft Auto actually does
include boats who knew fun fact but
that's not to mention another instant of
Grand Theft Naval against her own soon
to be crew mate on the Barat another 2
and 1/2 years and Nami also assaulted an
officer of the Marines in Koko yashi
Village that's a another 2 years now of
course that's not to mention the 100
million berries that the cat burglar
stole all across the grand line and
while these berries were themselves
stolen from Pirates stealing is wrong
and the world government just wouldn't
tolerate any kind of that behavior and
that's the crew second instance of grand
Larsen which makes for an additional 6
years ah and then Vin smok Sanji as a
chef on the floating restaurant baratier
he assaulted a ranking marine officer
Lieutenant Commodore full body so that
gets him 2 years and also on the Baria I
have reports that straw had Luffy caused
property damage by firing a cannonball
into the restaurant and that he also
broke many dishes and snuck several
plates of food out without paying for
them however seph decided not to press
charges so I guess no worries here but
then in L town the entire straw head
crew consisting of five members at this
point once again resisted arrest This
Time by Captain smoka and that's 2 years
for each of them so an additional 10
years that's already 79 years in imple
down and the straw hats haven't even
arrived on the grand line yet and once
the straw hats do arrive in the grand
line their crimes became much grander as
well now I will dismiss roron no aaro's
100 Mur murders on Whiskey Peak duee to
that being a case of self-defense I
guess however that doesn't make things
any better for the crew after arriving
in the Sakura Kingdom formerly known as
drum Islands the crew committed treason
against the world government by deposing
wole drum's Sovereign ruler and that's
just going to be the first of many many
life sentences for straw Hat Luffy and
we're just going to say that a life
sentence in one piece is exactly 100
years since the lifespans are a little
bit different than in the real world
also want to say I'm one 100% now on
some list somewhere after Googling how
many years in prison I might get for
punching various world leaders I mean
please remind me to burn my laptop after
I finish recording this then in the
Kingdom of alabaster monkey deffy and
his crew of five additional Pirates are
each charged with resisting arrest twice
once in nanohana and again in the city
of rainbase 20 years that is in total
and that's not to mention the immense
property damage they CA in the capital
of arama so one year for that oh as well
as damage caused to the Tomb of the king
a certified historical side so an
additional year for that oh yeah and of
course then there is the defeat of Sir
crocodile one of the seven Warlords of
the sea employed by the world government
a crime for which there is actually very
little precedent and we'll say that a
warlord is worth half a monarch I guess
so 50 years and on top of it there was
the worst crime of all dining and
dashing in nanohana which is yet another
year then upon fleeing from alabasta
they once again evaded capture but this
time they flat the scene with the eight
of a vehicle and this actually leads to
a harsher sentence due to the
expenditure of government resources in
the pursuit as well as the increased
danger to law enforcement and civilians
and so that's 6 years for each crew
member which now includes Nico Robin so
that's another 36 years which uh if
you've kept track now brings the total
charges to
288 years in prison starting to sweat
yet straw hats because this is just a
drop in the bucket let's proceed with
the next charges on the island of GA
monkey deui is guilty of aggravated
assault against bellam the hyena it just
goes to show that no matter how
punchable someone's face is you just
can't go around one-shotting people left
and right so 5 years for that and yes
skypia is not a member State technically
of the world government but the straw
hats also wreaked havoc above the clouds
to begin with they denied paying the
entrance fee of 1 billion x s so one
year for bypassing tolls and trespassing
they also assaulted many officers of the
law here including Nami ramming the
captain of the white barretts with a
vehicle called a waiver so 6 years for
assaulting an officer and an additional
seven for vehicular assaults and in
addition to all of this the STW also
trespassed into the restricted location
called the upper yard in an example of
illegal border crossing so one more year
for that and then on the shipright
island of water 7 cyborg Frankie
committed Grand larsy once again when he
stole 200 million berries from oh the
straw hats before he joined them I guess
you know what there's actually a
surprising amount of inter crew theft
happening with the straw heads here I
mean only two times so far but it's kind
of weird that it happened twice six
years for that and then oh what do we uh
what do we have here assaulting officers
of the world government fuffy Zoro and
Frankie attacking zp9 special agents in
water 7 6 years and then we have a case
of destruction of prop where it seems
that Luffy and zaro demolished two
buildings on water 7 during a natural
disaster turns out that these Pirates
are even more destructive to water 7
than the aqua lagona that will be an
additional 5 years and then next on the
sea train known as the puffing tum Vince
Mok Sanji and Cyborg Frankie disposed of
several Cipher pole agents again
including Jerry of cp6 w of cp7 and Nero
of cp9 and in Pursuit on a second train
roron Naro defeated the late vice
admiral T-Bone so8 more years for that
which now brings us right here to the
newly reconstructed in is Lobby do you
have any idea what the construction
costs are to place a building over a
giant gaping hole in the ocean it's
quite expensive now on the former old
NIS Lobby all eight of the straw hads
resisted arrest that's 8 years all of
them assaulted multiple Marine officers
at an average of five soldiers and
agents attack per crew member that's an
additional 80 years on top then freeing
a prisoner is worth an addition
5 years so for freeing both cyborg
Frankie and Nico Robin that's another 10
in total oh and oops how could I forget
the big one because for illegal
declaration of war against the world
government each member of the straw hats
earns an additional life sentence of 100
years and I think another 800 years in
imple down should give them plenty of
time to reflect on their actions so far
now for anyone keeping track that makes
the total charges thus far
1,230 years and you may think what's the
point of even going further surely the
straw hats will all rot in jail if
they're there that long well I do regret
to inform you that this is still nothing
compared to the heinous crimes to come
yet like the 50 years they get for
taking geodia out of commission on
Thrilla bark but even that is nothing
because then oh then we do go to sabba
Odi archipelago punching the king of a
member nation of of the world government
like wole is one thing but the punching
of St Charlos a Celestial Dragon and a
god that is 200 years oh and of course
there's the 16 years to per crew member
for a resisting arrest once again oh and
uh an additional year will be tacked on
for inciting a riot because that was a
real mess that kizaru and Kuma had to
clean up there then after Sab ODI
archipelago Luffy booked a direct flight
to Amazon Lily that he didn't pay for
the island of women where he engaged in
the high crime of being a man now how
many years does a person get in prison
for being a man well I'm just going to
say like uh 20 years 20 20 years for
being a man oh and Frankie blew up one
of Dr Vega Punk's old Labs on Baltimore
so that's another too and then from one
place where Luffy was absolutely not
supposed to be he went straight to a
place he even more was absolutely not
meant to be and it says here on my
forums that uh he sing singlehandedly
conducted the largest breakout in the
entire history of impel down the charge
for freeing a prisoner is actually 5
years as we've covered earlier and it
says here that you've freed
241 prisoners oh let's see 241 * 5 carry
the one that's another
1,25 years in prison Luffy of course
straw head then went straight to the
Marine Ford War he dropped a marine ship
onto the battlefield damaging government
property to the tune of 10 years he
freed yet another prisoner portgaz a for
another five which now comes to a total
of
2,739 years in prison and then oh wow
I'm impressed this pirate crew somehow
managed to lay low and didn't commit any
crimes for two entire years I mean if
they had waited about like three more
years they could have beaten the statue
of limitation on some of these previous
charges but nope they just can't help
themselves Pirates just love committing
crimes don't they because upon the straw
heads returned to sabba OD they straight
up destroyed government property in the
form of several pacifista robots and
what a shocker all my crew members
resisted arrest that's another 28 years
after that it appears that the crew
traveled beneath the red line to Fishman
Island where they ah committed a Cuda
tying up the monarch of Fishman Island
Neptune and taking over the castle for
this attempted government takeover of a
member nation of the world government
only 20 years that's that's very little
oh that's because King Neptune decided
not to press charges but this offense
against the government will not be
tolerated at the brand new Enis Lobby
number two next in the laboratory on
Punk Hazard the straw has destroyed
scientific property as well as committed
aggravated assault against the scientist
Caesar Clown that will be an additional
7 years and then moving over to Dres
Rosa Luffy defeated donkey HHA
doflamingo and doflamingo was not only a
warlord he was the king of a world
government member State and on top of
that all he was a Celestial Dragon and
that means that his defeat has earned
Luffy a combined
350 additional years in level seven of
imple down oh yeah and what happens
everywhere This Crew goes they resisted
arrest attacked Marines they incited
riots and rebellions 10 years for each
Straw Hat crew member and then next on
the island of Zo oh wait oh it appears
that the straw hats defied all logic and
expectations and did not commit any
crimes on the island of Zo unbelievable
but next after leaving zo the crew then
determined to invade two Emperor
territories those of big mom and kaido
respectively now yes those are not
member states of the world government
however cyop pole agents were present on
both occasions to observe the crimes of
all of the straw hats which were
shockingly similar in both territories
in both cases the straw heads committed
illegal border crossings one year each
for the 10 crew members and in both
cases crew members stole large amounts
of food one year Monkey De Luffy caused
immense property damage 5 years for
inciting Rebellion against the
government of wano country 10 years for
aggravated assault against many many
many individuals 50 years and for
wedding and or party crashing let's just
say one more year for good measure oh
yeah and uh for creating a power vacuum
in the entire world power by defeating
big mom and kaido an additional two 100
years yeah I mean they are not world
government Kings but they were crucial
to balancing the complex forces of the
world and that balance is now completely
out of the window which now brings us to
egad Island the government-owned lab run
by Dr Vega Punk the government scientist
and for the combined crimes of resisting
arrest attacking Marine officers
breaking into a top secret government
facility and aiding a known criminal in
the form of Dr Vega Punk who defied
government orders you have all earned an
additional 150 years oh and for
attempting to attack one of the five
Elder Stars Jay garia Saturn another 300
years but if you thought that that was
everything there are of course also a
few other high crimes that the straw
heads have committed one for flying the
Jolly Roger and acting in defiance of
the world government 10 years for each
Straw Hat crew member so 100 years and
in addition to that there's also a
100-year life sentence for Nico Robin
for possession of State Secrets due to
her ability to re the poneglyphs so far
that brings us to
4,171 years of rotting away in impel
down plenty of time for these Pirates to
soak in the guilt of their actions until
their dying breath except perhaps the
skeleton does he even breathe of course
and let one crime out the long-nosed one
Captain usapp wait do they have two
captains oh he goes by God now very
humble anyway Usopp the false reporting
of a crime such as that pirates are
attacking your village is a mem offense
punishable by up to one year in prison
evidently you did this every single day
for 10 years which adds up to
3,650 years in prison this brings each
of your years in the depths of imple
down to
7,821 years though I have heard rumors
that this man has even Allied himself
with the Giants of elbaff and so before
I can dismiss this court to see the true
threat that these Pirates are we are
next going to watch this video right
here about all the things that will
happen on the island of elb